moving on our main story tonight
concerns housing the thing that 16 year
old tiktok millionaires can afford and
you can't
housing is something tv audiences can't
seem to get enough of whether it's
watching angry couples hunt for the
perfect place to get divorced in or
watching celebrities giving
architectural digest tours of their
homes as they discover things that were
clearly put there by stylists and
occasionally call it out in a gloriously
passive aggressive way i love cooking i
cook a lot and i bake a lot i love limes
i love them they're great i love them so
much and i like to present them like
this in my house
she is so magnificently weird now real
dakota heads will know that she later
claimed she is in fact actually allergic
to limes saying it was hard to ignore
them so i just lied but she may well
have been lying about that as well she's
pure chaos i love her she should be the
president but
this story isn't going to be about
people who own their own lime infested
homes it's going to be about the more
than a third of american households who
rent and if you do rent you'll
undoubtedly be aware of what's been
happening recently tonight skyrocketing
rinse forcing a growing number of
americans to think twice about where
home is rent prices across the country
skyrocketing rents are rising nationwide
rents are going way way up yeah rent is
skyrocketing and that is the last thing
that you want to hear is on the rise
along with covert cases murder rates and
henry kissinger's life expectancy the
[ __ ] just won't quit will he
the median monthly asking rent in the
u.s surpassed two thousand dollars for
the first time last month that is up 15
since the same time last year well above
the rate of inflation and it's up over
30
in cities like cincinnati seattle and
nashville and nearly 50
in austin you or someone you know may
well be struggling to find a place right
now or are being priced out of where you
currently live by your landlord but the
fact is rent affordability isn't a
remotely new problem if you live in new
york your city became unaffordable to
rent in in 2004.
see this line that line is 30 of what
you make generally for rent it's advised
you don't spend past that line but if
you live in miami you probably passed
that line in 2001 and in chicago in 2012
los angeles has been playing
unaffordable since before 1979.
rent is growing faster than the money
most people make to pay it it's true
rent is growing faster than wages it's a
problem we've known about for decades
and is only getting worse which was i
believe a working title for this show it
was either that or america's saddest
home videos with adult mclovin
in fact
you're laughing too hard at that
in fact right now there is not a single
county in the u.s where a worker earning
minimum wage can afford a modest
two-bedroom rental home and look there
are undoubtedly individual landlords out
there who behave decently to their
tenants but many others will
conveniently blame the market rate for
extortionate rent hikes and imply that
the decision simply isn't theirs to make
just watch financial guru dave ramsey
try and reassure one landlord who said
he felt guilty about raising his rents
above what his tenants could afford
if i raise my rent to be market rate
that does not make me a bad christian
i did not displace the person out of
that house if they can no longer afford
it the marketplace did
the economy did
the ratio of the income that they earned
to their housing expense displaced them
i didn't cause
any of that of course kicking someone
out of your house doesn't make you a bad
christian it's in the beatitudes blessed
are the poor in spirit for theirs is the
kingdom of heaven [ __ ] to the poor in
money for theirs is the kingdom of
landlords
so
given that rents are going up and some
landlords seem to think that that's
completely unavoidable we thought
tonight we'd look at rental housing why
it's increasingly expensive how steeply
the system is stacked against renters
and what we can do to combat that and
let's start with understanding our
current housing supply you'll often hear
that high rents are a supply and demand
issue basically too many renters not
enough units and that is partially true
because there are currently not nearly
enough affordable units in the us which
is a little weird to think about isn't
it because if you live in any city you
probably see new buildings cropping up
all the time called things like four
east or summit 311 with taglines like
luxury urban dwellings driven by design
there's almost certainly a coffee shop
without a bathroom on the ground floor
so apartments are being built but the
problem is thanks in part to local nimby
opposition to more affordable
multi-family housing it's mainly been at
the high end in fact in the last three
decades the national stock of rental
units available actually grew by more
than 13 million but crucially the number
of units at the lowest end of the market
fell by nearly four million that might
be why if you've ever tried to search
for affordable apartments in your area
google just says nope
and this serious lack of new affordable
housing has enabled landlords to charge
higher rents for the units that exist
something that has increasingly
attracted institutional investors these
are corporate landlords like private
equity firms or even publicly traded
companies that pool the rents of their
tenants and sell them as investments
they've long been players in apartment
rentals but more recently after the 2008
housing crash companies like these
popped up to snap up single-family homes
and rent them out and because
institutional investors are always
trying to maximize returns they'll take
any opportunity to push rents higher
take monarch which has been called
middle america's fastest growing
landlord here is their owner last year
salivating at the prospect of rent hikes
we have an unprecedented opportunity at
least in my working lifetime to really
press rents press rents on renewals
because the country is highly occupied
we're 97.5
and so where are people gonna go they
can't go anywhere they wanna be an
apartment so they have to be in
apartments and we have a tremendous
opportunity to press both on renewing
leases for existing
residents and to reset market rates
which we've reset numerous times even
this year
wow they can't go anywhere and for us
that's an unprecedented opportunity to
press them that is a terrible way to
talk about people honestly it's barely
an acceptable way to talk about paninis
those sandwiches can't go anywhere [ __ ]
it press them squeeze those [ __ ] i
want to see lines
so if you are wondering why your rent is
going up it may well be because your
landlord sees the current affordable
housing crisis as a chance to reset
market rates and in a lot of the country
there are very few legal constraints to
stop them doing that you may have heard
of rent control which strictly limits
how much a landlord can charge you but
vanishingly few people have access to
that anymore more commonly there's rent
stabilization which in theory means that
on certain older properties landlords
can only raise the rent by a certain
percentage per year but only two states
and dc require it and more than 30
states have actually passed laws banning
it and even when protections exist
landlords can find ways around them for
instance they might try and force rent
stabilized tenants out by allowing a
property to fall into disrepair or by
harassing them with incessant
construction until they voluntarily
leave take the rent stabilized tenants
who lived in this building in new york
their landlord claimed that he was
simply upgrading it to improve tenants
quality of life but that is not how it
felt to them
tenants say they were offered buyouts to
leave but some like george manitos and
gretchen mongrein who've lived here for
almost 10 years opted to stay a decision
they say came with a warning well if you
don't take the buyout we are going to
renovate this and you are going to have
to live through the nightmare of
renovation mondrain says the unit next
to her was demolished with a crowbar
when she asked about the noise and
debris left behind all the person said
was
i just want to let you know there's
going to be a lot of rats from now on
you know it says a lot that they would
endure a rat littered construction site
just to hold on to a rent-stabilized
unit because that is not exactly a
welcoming message if you went to
someone's home and their welcome mat
said there's going to be a lot of rats
from now on you would drop your
casserole dish then and there and turn
the [ __ ] around thereby instantly
falling right into the rat's trap
and it is worth noting when rent
stabilized tenants did leave that
building the asking rents unsurprisingly
then as much as doubled and i assume
that those apartments were then snapped
up by a nice young rat couple with rich
taste and disposable income i believe we
have a photo yeah there it is yeah
they seem nice
and with rents being squeezed across the
board and protections few and far
between lower income renters are
obviously the most vulnerable here even
before the pandemic struck 23 million
people lived in households that paid
more than half their income on rent and
utilities which is just not sustainable
for anyone now in theory we have
something designed to combat that
federal housing assistance in the form
of housing choice vouchers commonly
known as section 8. the idea behind them
is that a household still has to pay 30
percent of its monthly income for rent
and utilities but the government
will then help cover the rest the
problem is this program is massively
underfunded to the point that only one
in four households that qualify for
assistance actually receive it as we've
shown on this show before sometimes
people have literally raced to apply for
vouchers when they became available and
even once you have applied the waiting
period can be absurd take chicago
alderwoman jeanette taylor whose
application
took a ridiculously long time to be
approved when did you apply for this
voucher in 1993 and when did you get it
2020 too
so 29 years what was your reaction when
you got that letter i just sat on the
side of the bed for like an hour and
shot and i was like god you got a sick
sister you'll be i mean
she's right
he does although to be honest i kind of
prefer god's earlier stuff convincing
abraham to almost kill his son as a
prank very funny flooding the world and
making one guy get every animal species
to [ __ ] on a boat hilarious but a
housing voucher there's 29 years late i
don't know that that does start to feel
like god might be running out of ideas
and the thing is even if you are lucky
enough to get a voucher you still then
have to find a landlord willing to
accept it but many landlords don't
either because they see it as a
bureaucratic hassle or because they have
a stigma against section 8 recipients
all of which leads to a lot of stories
like these
i was blessed with the home and choice
voucher in april
and
haven't been able to find a spot i
called over 200 places that would
supposedly take the voucher and
none of those places were actually
renting how many places do you think you
got turned down from
jesus
at least 15. 15 places
it's like i have a plague
it's like we
have a plague everywhere you turn no
section 8 i've called up 50 apartment
complexes in sacramento that they don't
look at me as an individual i'm on
section 8 therefore i'm poor
therefore i'm bad that is terrible
because even the worst people will honor
vouchers take willy wonka sure he may
have run a sweatshop with horrible
safety protocols that put children's
lives in danger but even he had the
decency to honor the [ __ ] vouchers
now discrimination against those with
section 8 vouchers is illegal in some
places but even where that is the case
landlords can just invent other reasons
to turn people away and with housing
this tight rents skyrocketing and
landlords holding this much power low
income renters can be left vulnerable to
the nightmare scenario eviction we've
talked about evictions on this show
before they're invasive traumatizing and
like all the other perils of renting
disproportionately affect black people
one study of more than a thousand
counties found black renters made up
around 20 of all adult renters but
nearly a third of all eviction filing
defendants and perhaps nowhere
demonstrates the enormous power
imbalance between landlords and tenants
more than housing courts starting with
the fact that in most places tenants
don't have a right to a lawyer in
eviction proceedings and if you don't
have an attorney to guide you through
what can be a complex process not only
can you fail to raise legitimate
defenses you can make basic mistakes
with huge consequences
gina comes across a tenant sitting
distraught so she came to court
dutifully came to court early and as
happened sometimes because court is
confusing she sat in the wrong courtroom
while her case was heard in a different
courtroom when she realized her mistake
she dashed over and caught the landlord
outside but he doesn't want to speak
with him and the court informed her that
after 10 days the sheriff would come in
and remove her and her three children
from her home
one tiny mistake and her housing was
gone which is clearly unfair the only
time someone should be punished for
going into the wrong room is when they
accidentally stumble into the 3 30
showing of downton abbey a new era
because get ready for a long boring ride
but john is delightful because they're
british counterpoint it is not
one study of nearly a hundred thousand
eviction cases in denver found that
nearly 90 percent of landlords were
represented by a lawyer compared to less
than one percent of tenants which is not
good and yet some attorneys who work for
landlords get very angry at the
suggestion that tenants are poorly
protected take this guy who represents
multiple landlords in st louis he's a
self-styled guru for the real estate bar
and just listen to him giving a zoom
seminar about evictions and rolling his
eyes at some of the basic legal
protections extended to renters during
covid
the advocates for the tenants are like
you know these people still don't know
what's available to them and they don't
know anything about the cdc declaration
they're too stupid
to know what their legal rights are they
shouldn't have signed a contract
for a thousand dollar a month unit for a
year
if they're too
stupid
to sign to to know anything to read the
news to have any idea about their rights
if they're too
stupid they shouldn't be signing a
twelve thousand dollar contract okay
first that is definitely the angriest
i've ever seen anyone wearing a rush hat
and second there's just no doubt in my
mind that that man at some point in his
life has been kicked out of a youth
soccer game he just exudes ref i'd like
a word energy
i guarantee that is a man who has thrown
a lawn chair or at the very least
squeezed a kool-aid jammer so tight in
his fists the other parents thought his
hand was covered in blood besides that i
will say he seems like a cool guy
so that is what tenants can be up
against and the problem is eviction
filings can be on your record for years
jeopardizing your chance at future
housing just watch as this woman
contacts a realtor about a home that she
is interested in did you get a chance to
drive by and take a look at it yeah i'm
sitting in front of the home right now
as we speak
okay and what's your name uh margaret
okay margaret and how soon are you
looking to move into a house um
as soon as possible
right now
are you on a lease where you're living
at right now no as a matter of fact uh
we're not we're
actually homeless
okay and so where are you currently
living
uh in our vehicle
unfortunately when we check the court
[Music]
look there are some things that should
probably stay on your record like war
crimes or voting for taylor hicks in the
2006 season of american idol you
shouldn't get to come back from that so
easily but
people should have a chance to find safe
and affordable housing since the
alternative is being homeless and the
thing is you could be turned down for
housing simply because an eviction case
was filed against you even if that case
was later dropped or indeed you won it
the long-term damage that eviction
filings do to your records is why many
will choose not to fight when a landlord
tries to kick them out that is one of
the reasons that people can wind up with
a so-called informal eviction that's
where their landlord does things like
change the locks threaten them or even
remove the front door it is hard to
measure just how many of these take
place each year but a survey of
milwaukee renters found that for every
eviction executed through the judicial
system there are two others executed
outside the court without any form of
due process
and given just how devastating evictions
can be it is infuriating to hear how
some involved in the process view it
remember that screaming rush fan from
earlier well it turns out he actually
has a little more to say it's sad to say
and some of you who are not landlords
might be shocked to hear we evict
grandparents
who are poor
we evict
cancer stricken people who are attending
chemo
it's sad
but what's sadder
is that
somebody who purchases
property for hundreds of thousands of
dollars
is given the finger
by the law
except it's not sadder
it's just not
on the great big list of sad things
person getting evicted during chemo is
right up there with dog deaths and the
first 10 minutes of up
while landlord doesn't get rent is at
the very bottom with celebrity tweets
about a shitty airline experience and
white guy not allowed to wrap all the
lyrics it's objectively not that sad at
all
that is the core issue with rental
housing in this country though people
who think that investments deserve more
respect than basic human needs and it
has set up a system designed to ensure
that some people just spiral downwards
they can't move somewhere cheaper if
nowhere cheaper exists they can't apply
for federal assistance if there's
nowhere near enough they can't even use
that assistance if no one accepts it and
they can't take their landlord to court
if the court system is skewed against
them and they can't depend on rental
housing ever again if they're evicted
even just once it's a complete [ __ ] show
so what can we do about it well there
are some small things that we could pass
um we could pass rent stabilization laws
uh and and laws that prohibit
discrimination against recipients of
housing choice vouchers and make it
easier for landlords to accept them we
could also pass laws mandating the
ceiling of most eviction records and
give people a right to council in
housing court that alone can have
massive impacts in 2017 after sustained
pressure new york city became the first
place in the country to give tenants the
right to a lawyer in housing court it is
a major reason why even before the
pandemic moratoriums residential
evictions were down 40 percent and
luckily other places are now following
that lead but i would argue
what we really need to do is
fundamentally change our mindset away
from simply hoping that we can tinker
around the edges of housing policy and
the private market will sort the rest of
this [ __ ] out because we have tried that
for decades and yet here we are instead
we need to agree housing is a human
right and that is not actually just some
empty slogan like subways eat fresh or
gatorades is it in you which looking
back
was very very weird
this can actually be policy many
countries including france scotland and
south africa have legally codified a
right to housing and here in the u.s
three-quarters of americans already
believe that it is a human right now as
for what that would mean it would entail
a massive federal investment in rental
assistance and the creation of much more
affordable housing units across the
board and before anyone suggests that we
can't afford that
we already subsidize certain people's
homes the mortgage interest deduction
gives massive subsidies to homeowners by
letting them deduct the interest that
they pay on their mortgage on their
taxes that has cost the federal
government more than 580 billion dollars
over the last decade and currently
nearly two-thirds of deductions benefits
are going to those making 200 000 or
more a year i am benefiting from this
program and i do not need to be so we
are clearly willing to prioritize
housing in the budget just not for the
people who need it the most the point
here is for a large portion of the
population simply having a place to live
is an everyday battle and for far too
long we've prioritized the protection of
investments over individuals and we've
set up a system where landlords can
press rents and reset market rates and
justify their actions with self-serving
bible readings even as they subject
tenants to everything from tactical rat
assaults to the incoherent rage of the
single most foul-mouthed fan ontario's
premier prog rock power trio has ever
[ __ ] known
you